thrilled to have back here on the rich
eisen show the man whose virtual comedy
show
behind the mask drops as the kids say
saturday to september 12th at 7 00 pm
uh the show will be streaming on rush
ticks r-u-s-h-t-i-x dot com where
tickets are available and brad paisley
opening up
for our next guest kevin how are you
kevin hey rich
good to talk to you again good to talk
to you do you know what i mean by going
higher register for things that you kind
of believe but you really don't you know
like you ever you ever find yourself
doing that
yes absolutely in fact that's my that's
my motto
always always kind of like second guess
always try and think see how it might
actually go uh how's life for you what
are you what are you what have you been
up to except getting ready for your
virtual
uh comedy show have you ever asked
anybody that question and they say
you know what rich life has never been
better for me i mean what a sad life
that must be
well you know what it's an open-ended
question because i've also never had
somebody then say you know life is
miserable and then pour out their
troubles for the next five minutes like
it's a therapy session i've never had
that
one thing i realize from visiting my
parents in a retirement home is never to
ask a stranger in the hallway how
they're doing
[Laughter]
you will have to pull up a chair and sit
down and listen to a litany of medical
uh issues like don't ask right yeah
yeah but things are doing well for me
thanks for asking i mean considering
everything um you know i think all of us
are kind of
settling into this you know temporary
normalcy
right right now and um and you know it's
talking about the vaccine
about that but you know in the meantime
i've just you know i'm excited like you
that sports is kind of back
sort of you know it's it's um it's like
we're making the best of things you know
like not nothing is like what it was
like this virtual
you know live stream show i'm doing it's
gonna be from my office in my home
it's gonna be great but it's not gonna
be like uh coming from a comedy being in
a comedy club live
it's kind of like the blow up doll of
comedy clubs you know it's a good
substitute
so you're gonna basically be again
just sitting in your home office doing
stand-up jokes
is there going to be in the same way
that the nfl or others are pumping in
crowd noise like well will laughter be
pumped in
as well kevin or you're just going to do
your jokes first of all i won't be
sitting because it's a stand-up show so
i will be
i will have a mic i will be standing up
it will be in my office which by the way
is also my safe room
and um nobody will be rushing the stage
yes and the audience will they'll be
about
10 to 20 people that you could hear
their laughter
you know but you won't see them so i'll
be able to kind of like get my timing
from them oh my gosh
yeah so it's i'm excited about it
actually i'm
i'm uh because my stand up um
is it's kind of laid back it's kind of
intimate i've always preferred the
smaller rooms
as compared to the larger venues like
theaters and arenas right
and this is probably nothing more
intimate than this
venue well i mean because you keep
hearing you know uh athletes who are
coming back and there's no fans that
they say that it's really odd that you
can't feed off them
so you you will will there at least be
members of your family
in your safe room to laugh at your stuff
or no the only person that will be
nearby
in my home yes and that night will be mr
brad paisley
and we have been potting together since
the covet started and we're all covered
free
including our kids our kids are best
friends and our wives are best friends
are you
serious yeah yeah and i just kind of put
up with brad
you know you put up with me so that's
your
that's your pod is the kneelings and the
paisleys have been chilling and quarant
it's your quarantine friends yeah yeah
yep uh what i would like to do though
richard i would like to
um also include bill gates and his
family
and i would tell him bill let's pod
together let's prove our money
yes let's put in a big pile let's live
off of that during the
covet and when this is all over we'll
just split that pile down the middle and
go our separate ways
i like it so it's kind of like again the
night that
uh michael jordan and i uh combined for
55 points on his 55-point night
and that'll just take sort of like that
sort of thing exactly
exactly that i like it kevin and plus
you know i've got some of my best laughs
from my home here so i have high
expectations
you know i'm going to that next level
and that's rushtix.com where you can
check out kevin helen behind the mask
brad will be opening for me he'll be my
house band and there's an after party a
virtual
after-party ritual okay just let me
repeat that again virtual after party
where people can hang out
we could chat with them they'll ask
questions there's a two-drink minimum if
it's honorary they got to go to
and take out two dreams of any story of
any sort okay
and then and that'll be that and then
you tip your virtual waitress and then
that'll be it
yeah and then here's another thing an
idea i had richard like maybe maybe you
could give me your thoughts on this okay
uh you know a social distance distancing
in sports
what about wrestling each wrestler
ruffles from their own home
virtual wrestling how does how does that
work kevin i'm i'm
first of all color me interested um
how does it work in your estimation then
here's how it works it's like okay let's
say ufc you know how they fight in the
ring
yes okay what we do is
we get two fighters yeah
and we
have them each fight from their own home
they watch the other person's move
yes and then they do their move they do
their punch the other one does their
punch and then the ref
from his home um kind of
like you know judges like whether that
would have landed or not
[Laughter]
so it's interpretive essentially what
you're saying
ufc fighting yes and then it's
interpretive um you've got to
suspend your uh disbelief a little bit
use your own imagination
um what so how does one decide to
uh when you know well there's a tap out
the
no that's the that's the leave red
button at the bottom of your
zoom kevin that's right that's to leave
now
[Laughter]
we're both spitballing here kevin i'm
getting that sense
well you know everything is footballing
now there's no there's no uh there's no
virtual spitballing just virtual because
the other way could be dangerous
i mean it wouldn't be dangerous if they
made the ring bigger
and they still had to keep six feet
apart and they wore a mask
they couldn't touch each other but they
had to say six feet apart
oh my gosh it's almost like a three
stooges uh kind of a sketchy
yeah that would be difficult uh if you
want to talk about comedy that's
difficult and uh social distancing three
stooges would be particularly difficult
you know yeah that would be very
difficult kevin nealon behind the mask
virtual comedy tour again tomorrow night
saturday september 12th at 7 p.m uh
pacific 10 o'clock
eastern time uh we're on right now on
the peacock streamer
uh kevin and uh on a standalone channel
that's nbc
sports on peacock that's another
standalone channel for saturday night
live
where you go right there and it just
doesn't stop it's one
after another after another bits and
shows
from your era 86 to 95
if you had one yes exactly correct yeah
it's up there too
yeah you're on the peacock peacock
platform on the peacock streamer that
we're on right now
um so we've got that going on which one
of your arrow that you would say
that was the one like if you had to have
one time capsule
from your era of saturday night live
that you were involved in which one
would it be for you
i would probably be like 100 franz or
something you know with arnold
schwarzenegger okay
but you know it's funny because my son's
13 and he
loves watching saturday night live
online okay
but it's the current ones you know like
maybe going back eight years
seven years but not yours not your not
your
because no he can't really find that and
sometimes i have to remind them i get a
little jealous and say
hey you know i was on that show one time
you know for nine years
and the payday you know you should check
those out check out those sketches
yeah i want to do that and then he's
showing me all these sketches that are
kind of like
you know comedy kind of changed over the
years where it's a little more kind of
like inappropriate now
and um naughty and you know it's always
been naughty but
on snl it's more short attention span
you know and the characters
break up laughing and you know they
don't stay in character
and so the other day i came across some
uh
sketches on my computer that i had saved
from snl some of my favorite ones
and i sat them down i said okay i'm
going to show you some real snl stuff
here some vintage
and i was showing it to him and he was
standing and i always look at his face
when he's watching a show that i wanted
to see i don't look at the show because
i know it
yes i'm watching his reactions and it's
kind of like he was just being nice to
me though that's
oh that's funny oh that's funny oh no
but i realized that they were kind of
long you know the sketches went on for a
while and they should have been shorter
and they're not as funny as i really
want them to be
did you have to explain to him like say
who brent musburger was like that's
funny you know like i you know i'll
watch tv with him now or a movie
and he'll be next to me and he'll always
say is that guy
uh still alive is she still alive and
i'll say yeah that's sandler that's adam
sandler he's still alive
what i say good rule of thumb is if the
movie's in black and white
those people are mostly dead so wait a
minute hold on a second kevin nealon
here on the show
you've been if i'm not mistaken your hit
rate of you being in a sandler movie
um is up there with like you know alan
covert you know what i mean like
it's up there with you've been in what
90 of them
most of them um i don't think so i think
i've been in about i think i counted
maybe 13 and i've been on you know his
album one of his albums
okay that's a hypnotist so does he know
i've done different things
has he never seen you in a sandler movie
then is it what you're saying
oh yeah he has okay i've seen a couple
you know that
i mean he only kind of got to the age
where he could start watching that stuff
now and even now it's a little
i kind of cringe a little bit on certain
scenes right um
but i do want to show him these movies
that are he's not quite right for like
the jerk the steve martin movie okay
and i think what's wrong with that i
don't think there's anything r in there
rated r but i think where's vr stuff and
then you start playing you go oh
that's right
[Laughter]
if there's only a website for that sort
of thing you know i mean
interesting yeah no i mean so the scenes
of like swardson would definitely be
inappropriate for your son
oh you could imagine yeah yeah in some
movies yeah you know but yeah
some of the sports and movies
you know he he knows all the he knows
all the square words
but he used to be kind of awkward when
somebody would say the s word or
you know the f word now he kind of he
hears it at school all the time and when
i say school i mean online
[Laughter]
watching the uh the ufc online sport
that we just uh we just workshopped
um hey man this is a fun chat as always
kevin thanks for coming on let's do it
again
um and i look forward to having you back
here in person when uh when all this
insanity is over thanks rich i love you
and i love your show
great man thanks for having me thank you
right back at you kevin nealon at kevin
underscore neeland
behind the mask virtual comedy show
tomorrow
at 10 eastern 7 pacific go to rush ticks
r-u-s-h-t-i-x dot com brad paisley is
opening up for him
do you think he really is quarantining
with the paisleys is it because you
never
like i can't tell you can't tell
i gotta go yes or no yes or no no no
he's not
i don't know although i i know
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here